[Musique]
allez venez de gaspard la scène cruciale
parce que je défie mon
l'ennemi on va dire publiquement en
allant faire un gros un gros concert
sauvage pas du tout prévu devant ça
devant sa prison allez voit la
figuration et ça arrive comme des
zombies ces démarcheurs dans les danses
étaient disposés avec la scène en hopman
les bras qu'ils ont utilisée pour filmer
aussi c'était quelque chose
d'impressionnant quand même il va y
avoir le premier est pas qu on fait la
machinerie dont une telle grille va
commencer à être en mouvement
les portois
c'était lourd c'était l'ordre faire un
concert dans une prison dehors et que le
monde qui avait la foule les filles ans
et c'était vraiment l'eau et la presta
dati qui est incroyable c'est le mois
des bonnes comme si je faisais un vrai
concert comme si je faisais mon vrai
concert parce que c'est moi qui écris
leçon
tu parles arrive aussi c'est tous les
jours ils ont particulièrement apprécié
ce moment parce qu'il faut savoir que
dans tous les figurants et avec beaucoup
de mecs de nos quartiers tels fierté
pouvoir partager ça avec eux
impressionnant plus on est en reprise
libre en prison c'est quelque chose
actuellement on est à la prison de
fleury mérogis dans une aile désaffectée
de l'ancien centre de jeunes délinquants
de fleury mérogis
je me rappelle très bien que l'équipe
arrive le matin comme tous les matins
depuis hier que d'un coup on se rend
compte qu'on est l'arrêt puis ça crée
une ambiance un peu particulière sans
mettre d'ici à vol d'oiseau il ya des
mecs qui sont en cellule des fois de
plus 20 piges jésus dira de mac tyer
donc un des rappeurs qui joue son propre
rôle dans la série qui tourne sa scène
aux parloirs à fleury mérogis et quand
il arrive sur le tournage m'a tout de
suite dit j'étais dans cette cellule là
pendant trois ans une création originale
à découvrir en avant-première en ce
moment sur my canal